oh yeah ladies and gentlemen welcome to
multiple players yeah Chris waters here
with Mary Kish and Mary uh it's Monday
so you know sometimes I will talk about
like having a case of the mondays or not
like super stoked but how on scale one
to funky how funky are you feeling today
I also glad you asked I feel funky yes
because toejam and earl panic on funk
entradas a game we're playing in honor
of video game history month or playing a
little co-op platformer action here with
toejam and earl and like the funkiest
soundtrack forever in a game forever
this this game is near and dear to my
heart yeah alright what I won't you be
playin toejam since I was a little toe
tot tote art did you did you think about
that before you get all this yeah I
can't live with it just no hombre all
right not too bad thank you know Craig
the terrible news on funca Tron no no
it's been invaded by Earthlings and you
know whose fault that is well Obama on
too damn it Obama sending tourists to
Mars thanks a lot on the nudie guy
they're just doing their thing I
remember this new teasing a guy in the
box find all the Earthlings all right
now it sounds like looking in this bush
let's shake it easy the tree a shady
tree shape Oh get that all she catch you
yeah oh hi cool be cool man i'll chuck a
jar at a child's face and then we took
that child in a jar in a ship ship those
children and back to rocket them into
the Sun get rid of all them children no
more problem doesn't that make a share
health yes the high five move wish to
share health which means or are damaged
as it were all right here we go funky
forest oh yeah I'm gonna get funky
chanting japa japa japa jars everywhere
checking some trees gotta go with the
overlapping method press the button yeah
you just keep shaking it all that rock
is so into you pushing him he's loving
it
whoa all right press the button one on
TJ I was into that Ross huge looking
babe loving it so like all control it
now but now it switches in its you hmm
like in control oh I'm stuck the landing
no yeah can I get a good funks can sure
give it a shot oh yeah looking hell
there appears to be garbage in that
Treme away from that tree it's curbage
we don't want none of that oh wait get
back here what's this one I remember
that all this kid earth it's a child
hate it with jars kill it president got
away money damn dude eat jar bitched
snug it down pigtails all right are you
gonna press that button it's not very
funky of me I should be more classy oh
we did it yeah what's going on oh I
needed that anything look if a cake just
falls out of the sky on in my head I'm
gonna you did fine oh yeah yeah all
right we gotta do a real hot hot I
thought it was a hen thing what the
heads a definitely a high five I thought
they'd smash so clearly I five there's
like a streak for their hands and
everything cools like they smash their
heads I go in this door fine I feel like
you're not being very funky right now
you can we yeah you'd a hamburger
hamburger high five now Oh snub I'm a
move is your Hut cuz he loved this film
oh that rock is sooo yeah that's this
much oh yeah don't dance it up ya know
do you know how to do the boom clap do
it how do you know which boo is booming
what's club man your bc you're a funky
guy well let's see if I'm where am I on
the lamer awesome I'm like moderately
I'm fun for that weekend what mm-hmm
clap boom boom clap so not man I was so
awesome I was pretty decent Oh awesome
so much bunk I didn't go in pbone see
you later p though we can't always our
lives next to a boombox we got jobs
that's how you change levels they fling
you into outer space you gotta do the
poop face I don't know why no I know
you're cool you're cool I got it like a
nominal egg-cam that's cool hello again
oh you're in hyper folks own this press
a to ya yeah all right oh right this is
the bonus level a hyper funk zone as you
can tell it's super funky Mary's trying
to pick up the UH presents and at that
time but avoid those squiggly barriers
and avoid those portals back to a normal
[ __ ] Tron he probably got some time
coming up there you nice oh no this
present this can extend Oh lightning so
it can extend like three levels deep of
that but uh pretty solid if you try to
look more something and there's nothing
back there oh wait what where did I go
you just cold found a secret passage did
you know that of course I was incredible
you're trying to show a demonstration of
what happens when you press up and
nothing is there and you found a secret
passage game knows how funky is damn
mary is so funky hence my thong what up
that was tight hello just disappeared I
was legendary Oh Sonya on ice cream cone
for no reason num num num num all right
now you can't show me your butt yeah
that one don't you have to do that make
that booty [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was lame that's definitely not
gonna awesome second wow so good that
was thrown an extra booming Charlie got
some history gonna show me okay gimme
gimme me oh yeah fortune favors the
funky mary went all the way down here
get out of the under funk all right it's
getting a little too under funkier oh
yeah look at this spot look at how cool
this places they're running presents
you're so beautiful there's ice cream in
the meadow oh my goodness just jumping
ahead oh don't know it's a Sam guy he
makes you fall asleep I know I'm [ __ ]
he's rich we're gonna sucks right hate
that guy alright that kids coming down
suck it kid well no you can't catch it's
just Jarrah George you're in the face
okay go to school no not even have a
butt crack knows what this his alien
physiology is like well I don't I don't
I'm letting wearing pants no it's true
me exactly I'm a new team and a little
tribe don't was it for that medallion
all my genitalia would be well you do
have those gloves and those keys that's
where is where the magic happened ahead
apparently I gotta all right let's go
down this whole Weiner on my head all
right whoop you gotta you gotta stick
with it here cool no I'm still here Earl
coming along for the ride oh you got on
this bubble train oh no oh it's a naked
dude okay creeper you created hit him
while he's in the mob pervy dude you're
such a perv look he's just naked on
boxing off the singer okay
you are with the hate speech against
this guy just wants to run around in a
box and sing oh he's a nudie man you're
not down with it not down with a Judy
Lana box you got me wearing at Lisa
medallion yeah some kind of clothes on
yeah boy yeah you can hide / funk soul
hyper [ __ ] soon oh ha oh ha Oh bride oh
he's got it he's got it on lock now Oh
yet memorizing mhmmm saw coming back to
me oh so for that part my part didn't
come back to them Oh chin yeah oh he's
got it 1200 oh no miss Dietz right I got
some point we're deep funk now I'll go
walk walking too slow can't be walking
this slow oh right oh no you're in
trouble Oh Yolanda's my girl right that
is your girl obviously cuz she looks
kind of like you I'm glad you found me
TJ you or maybe she's into you I can't
tell it's my girlfriend oh she you're
just asking her straight up yeah girl oh
no she's not into it like that she is
just bummer turn it down age if you swim
back out of this cave and when you get
to the surface swim all the way to the
left and then is down as deep as you can
yellow deep
that because of the swimming because of
what lawanda said yes I'll go and I'm
ready you don't even have lips oh she
likes me oh we trying to do here get in
on that girl get some of this hot alien
action guess where much she is pretty
hot thing is you owe me take my hat off
I will take my nuts on top of my head
it's up on my I'm presenting yeah he
likes what she sees thumbs up she's like
yeah oh yeah get a closer look get a
good look oh yeah yeah well she's put
her hand on it oh yeah oh yeah about
them blurred lines get in on it alright
i can't i'm done with you you gotta hit
it and quit it oh look this is the
Wanda's mom you got to answer to her
look at their looking at it with a
straight face like you didn't just get
nasty with her girl down in the cave I
just showed your girl all my stuff every
tentacle I got a bunch of them oh no
cover your eyes cover your eyes cover
your eyes I'm freaking out I'll break it
out I think we've established your
position on super jar so we don't need
him Kip I'll turn around look oh look at
me grabbing your butt yeah oh come on
this is my tree what if i told you not
getting in my butt wiggle em control oh
you're always in front of me that is
inappropriate I'm getting [ __ ] with
you oh that's pretty funky oh yeah right
there fungus wiggle that wiggle that
funk tree yeah that is the definition of
co-op it's funky get down with your bad
self funky
hmm thank you for watching multiple
players told general panic on funkin
tron Mary Kish thank you for joining me
feel on the phone wait one more we're
gonna end on this
you